how has motherhood affected
i mean i'm sure you're a real lion i'm
guessing yeah i'm a mama bear when you
come to my family my child
but um i think that i'm very nurturing
to begin with and i think motherhood has
ignited even more that
you know a protection
to women
i think that
when you have a child whether it's a
little boy a little girl i think
education has to be is the foundation of
who they are when they're adulthoods and
so we have to um
teach them
how to you know this this is it's okay
to
to learn about sexual education but also
it's okay to learn about healthy
healthy relationships right that starts
in at home and it starts in uh at school
and that's exactly what my foundation do
i reach out to the communities and i
reach out to college and universities by
doing this the speeches and forums that
i do educating them about sexual abuse
and uh consent domestic abuse so if
we're your audience or we're your
daughter or we're some of the people
you're trying to reach out to how did
you make different choices
with your current partner
and
what do you teach people about what to
find acceptable and not acceptable
i think it all becomes with uh education
again and uh
you know th this is the the very essence
of
being
um a person
who before you judge somebody you have
to educate there there's a difference
between an educated judgment versus an
uneducated judgment so before you know
there's a lot of and i i told you know
even my my daughter so when i go to
school and i said look i mean you know
this is very important for you to learn
uh and also to learn to trust people
because you cannot live without your
life without trusting anybody i think
there's a very fine line be when you are
about to judge something or somebody
that you know
you hear
because the news are an opinion
of a person who's writing the news
not your own so that's very important to
actually understand that i like that
leading with trust is a more
kind open-minded open-hearted way to
live
however i imagine that you probably are
an authority on pattern and behavior so
is that something that you teach to the
new generation of specifically what to
look out for and not
accept as behavior coming at you yes
domestic violence is is based on
you know power and control and so when
you teach that
um behavior in behaviors can be learned
and also behaviors can be you know
correct so
when you learn that base uh i think it
becomes easy and it could change we
could actually change society knowing
the fact that uh one out of three women
are going to experience domestic abuse
in the lifetime
every
every eight seconds a woman gets abused
children get abused and so to me that
breaks my heart
and i think that education again is part
of it if we teach our children like i
said sexual
education we should teach them about
healthy relationships and that is
something very important that's part of
why i'm doing this documentaries and i
keep doing this documentaries because
it's very important to understand that
you know abusers are not going to let go
and um but you also said people can
change is it more the victim can change
or the abuser can change if they get the
right help help yeah i mean when he like
came out onto the scene it was such a
bizarre tone you if you haven't seen the
documentary i urge you to watch it
because it's such an extraordinary
journey with each part jordan peele as
he helps tell this narrative keeps you
on the hook because you just can't
believe the realities of the situation
when john wayne becomes a porn star and
celebrates this moment and sort of milks
it for money and attention how did that
make you feel
it was devastating because again how can
this person who have hurt me physically
emotional mentally
could be celebrated by society right i
do not understand that
[Music]
you